new restrictions everyday across the
world as each country fights its own
battle against the coronavirus in
Australia strict travel measures are
being implemented anyone arriving from
abroad must self quarantine for two
weeks
cruise ships entering Australian waters
will soon be banned from docking for 30
days
prime minister Scott Morrison says the
restrictions unnecessary and is called
for an urgent meeting of the g20 Prime
Minister Modi is keen to organize a
link-up between all the g20 leaders I
think that's I think that's a
commendable initiative Australia
obviously supports that and even more
urgent meeting that would be needed
would be a further meaning of the g20
finance ministers and central bank
governors this is a health crisis but it
has very serious economic impacts in New
Zealand the number of people infected
has gone up after a person traveled from
Australia despite having tested positive
for coronavirus the self-isolation
period of two weeks for travellers
entering New Zealand has come into force
but those coming from small South
Pacific island countries with no
reported cases are exempt we're going to
step up their enforcement things like
spot checks to ensure people are self
isolating and if you don't stand for
late there are quarantine powers
available to us and on New Zealand's
East Coast passengers on a cruise ship
docked in ocurro town are not allowed to
disembark three people on board are
quarantined with one showing symptoms
also in the Pacific region the
Philippine capital Manila has begun a
month's lockdown thousands of police are
sealing off the city by blocking major
roads the quarantine means domestic
travel in and out of Manila is suspended
with a few exemptions there's so much
traffic the containment measures are
disrupted but it's okay it's for the
good of our own health from Monday
Manila's 12 million residents will be
under a nightly curfew nur encouraged to
stay at home during the day schools are
closed most government jobs will be
suspended and large gatherings ought to
be banned
the Philippines has taken some of the
toughest measures yet in the region and
while people's movement is being
restricted officials hope it will
prevent a bigger spread of the virus so
to hide at al Jazeera